sad this will be the last
is
couldn't take more than we could so
making something out of nothing with a
scratch and a hole
is
think about it there must
in the be are hidden in the stars above
without it life is a wasted time
look inside your heart and i look inside
mine
falling
me
up
oh
things look so bad everywhere
me
i bring me
oh
don't listen to everybody baby
baby
tell me you want me
tell me
is
take a chance
baby
i gotta have you baby
oh
keep holding
say what you want ain't gonna change
i can't walk
and if you're expecting me to give you
an apology
until your face
oh
is
that's what they gonna change
hello hello
i'm viviana janer and i'm chairwoman of
the osceola board of county
commissioners
and i'm so excited to welcome you here
to kissimmee in osceola county
so as we prepare to welcome the vice
president
right here to osceola county i couldn't
pick
a better and more perfect day because
we're in the kickoff
and it's the first day of hispanic
heritage month and here in iowa county
we have an overwhelmingly hispanic
population with 55 percent
of our population being of hispanic
origin
with a great majority of them being
puerto rican
so we're a working class um
community and we had so many people
relocate from puerto rico after
hurricane maria
looking for opportunity unfortunately
right now
we're stuck with an inadequate and inept
in response to both hurricane maria and
our covet 19 pandemic
so i don't know about you but i'm so
looking forward to a president
that not only has a plan for puerto
ricans
for hispanics but also will bring that
level of respect
and caring to the white house that we
need
so with that said it gives me great
pleasure
as the first hispanic woman to uh serve
on the osceola board of commissioners
and the only puerto rican woman to serve
there
um in the history of osceola county to
introduce to you
the first boricua member of congress
from the state of florida the honorable
congressman
darren soto
espana welcome to our hispanic
heritage month celebration with vice
president
joe biden what an amazing way
to kick off this celebration of our
heritage here in central florida
with the vice president and as the
momento
la vota espana is critical in the lexian
presidential
the hispanic vote is critical
we must elect joe biden to the president
united states to solve the pandemic
to restore our economy and to build back
better mi familia is
espanol
vote for biden to save america
gracias
spoilers
hey
i
right
but the times have changed
i'm
me
oh
hello
you can live your life alone
is
yes
never had
oh
huh
allah
you know
please welcome eva longoria and ricky
martin
hello
we want to start this hello everyone
bienvenidos
if you know me you know i wish we could
all be together celebrating hispanic
heritage month together but that's not
the world we live in today
because for eight months the president
of the united states has
refused to implement a plan to bring
this pandemic to an end
a pandemic that has killed more than 194
000 fellow americans
including thousands of latinos and
latino brothers and sisters
his incompetence and cruelty has come as
a surprise for many americans
but not for our community we knew who he
was from the beginning
after hurricane maria
we saw how he tossed paper towels for a
photo up
while asking the cabinet if he could
sell puerto rica we witness his cruelty
when he launched his campaign by calling
immigrants rapists
and criminals as a president he deployed
eyes to implement barbaric policies
we also witnessed his shamelessness
when after a post nightclub shooting
here in florida
instead of comforting victims he tweeted
appreciate the congrats i am not killing
this is what he said
i appreciate the congress
we have good news not only do we have
the chance to defeat donald trump this
november
we have a chance to elect a president
who will rebuild america
a person a president we will be proud to
call
our commander-in-chief that's because
joe biden is
a man of character he believes
his family and mine are more similar
than different he believes everyone has
a place in this country
no matter where you were born what you
look like
or who you love joe biden is a president
who is ready to protect all puerto
ricans
it doesn't matter if you live in
pennsylvania it doesn't matter if you
live
in florida it doesn't matter if you live
in the island
he is ready to work for us
a president who will respect the dignity
of the puerto rican people a president
who has a plan
to provide relief from unsustainable
debt that is holding our economy back
who will listen to us whether we're
protesting outside of la fortaleza
or we're demanding action from the white
house that is exactly who joe biden is
with him as a president we will always
have a chair at the table but before
that happens
we have to make sure he wins i'm gonna
ask you
almost beg you to please you have to go
to
boyabout.com or i will vote.com and and
register now
we have to do this for our children we
have to do this
for the children of our children
you know guys i have to i like to have
fun
but this is really serious these are the
most important elections
these are the most important elections
we've seen in this history in this
country and puerto ricans have the power
to decide
us puerto ricans we have the power to
decide and we will use that power in
november
we have to make sure joe biden
goes to the white house i beg you please
go to voyage.com where i will vote.com
and make a plan make a plan
of what you're going to do that day how
are you going to get to the voting polls
but we have to do this we have to change
the course this country's going to
thank you
hello florida uh today kicks off the
first day of hispanic heritage month
which is a way to celebrate latino
culture and to
recognize our heritage that no matter
where you come from our culture and
heritage
is engraved in america
yet our community is reminded that we
are different
whether it's the accent on our last name
or the accent in our voice
whether it's the color of our skin there
are many in this country that believe we
don't belong
and as ricky said president's assault on
latino dignity
started on day one of his campaign
when he called us drug dealers and
rapists
and he has spent the last four years
doubling down
on demonizing latinos at the border he
has ripped kids from the arms of their
parents
and has locked them in cages i want
mothers everywhere to hear that
imagine your child being separated from
you
and put in a cage three feet away from
you where you cannot hold or console him
he's tried to deport dreamers even the
ones who serve
in uniform to protect the united states
of america
our soldiers are being deported
he abandoned puerto rico after hurricane
maria left the island in complete
devastation
he even thought maybe we could swap
puerto rico for greenland
because in his words puerto rico was
dirty and the people were poor
he's completely failed to respond to
covet 19 a virus that has
disproportionately
affected the latino community's health
and economic security
latinos are only 18 of the population
but we make up over 34
of essential frontline workers 34
that's your nurses those are your health
care workers your drivers your delivery
people your your farm workers who are
putting food on your table
farm workers have always been essential
we didn't need a pandemic to tell us
that
trump's strategy is to cast out latinos
as being less than fully american
well let me tell you how american we are
this year for the first time in history
hispanics will be the largest minority
group of potential voters in the united
states
latino voters will decide the 2020
election
that's a simple fact in florida where we
are today hispanics are even a bigger
part
of the population 25 percent compared to
nationally and i want to be clear
increasing hispanic pop hispanic
participation in elections
doesn't help democrats or republicans it
helps america
the media narratives try to reduce
hispanics to single-issue voters
immigration immigration immigration but
guess what our community cares about a
whole lot more
biden offers a very strong platform
and record on the economy on health care
and education under the obama biden
administration latino unemployment rates
declined more than seven percent
the previous administration joe biden
believes to his core that there's no
greater economic engine in the world
than the hard work and ingenuity
of the american people nobody has more
respect
for the working men and women who get up
every day
to build and sustain this country and
joe biden knows that many of those
hard-working people
are latinos
trump administration endorses economic
policies that reward wealth
over work and corporations over working
families
we are battling for the soul of the
nation
biden has a plan to create millions of
good paying jobs and give america's
working families
economic mobility for themselves and for
their children
we are battling for the soul of this
nation
mexico isn't sending drug dealers and
rapists they just sent firefighters
to help us fight the california
wildfires
they're trying to save american lives
puerto ricans are american
puerto rico isn't a foreign country
they're american citizens
we should be lifting them up it's more
than just coming around every four years
knocking on our door and saying hey your
vote matters
it's about showing us latinos our lives
matter our livelihoods
matter so i don't know about you but
after all the attacks and the insults
i don't just want donald trump out of
office but i want the latino community
to be the decisive group
that votes him out of office i want to
show our pride in our strength
and our power as a community that's why
i'm asking you to do everything you can
to elect joe biden and kamala harris
he's a family man a man of faith
throughout his career he has stood with
the latino community
and has shown that he values us for the
diverse and countless ways we make this
country great already
we need joe biden in the white house and
he needs our help to get there
there's no question that latino voters
can determine the outcome of this
election
and that starts right here in florida so
we have the numbers
it's up to us to make sure those numbers
add up to his victory this november
the cup of life
push it alone
might understand
please welcome luis fonsi
fancy
hello everyone
whether you're here in kissimmee or
watching our live stream
i'm so grateful you've chosen to spend
some time with us today
i'm so excited to have the chance you
know to talk to you about what's at
stake
in this election for the two places that
made me the man i am today
my beautiful puerto rico and florida
i was born in san juan puerto rico which
is where i fell in love with music
but during my early teenage years my
family and i moved
to orlando florida i actually graduated
not too far from here dr phillips high
school
in so many ways my story is the american
story
when i arrived in florida i could barely
speak english
by the time i left i knew what i wanted
to do with the rest of my life and the
fact that i realized that dream proves
that
in this country anything is possible
so despite everything we are facing i
still have hope
but i would be lying if i didn't
recognize that this
is one of the most difficult periods in
this country's history
and i'm not only talking about the
pandemic
and the economic crisis that comes along
with that i'm talking about
unity i'm talking about inclusion
i'm talking about acceptance all
of the values we use to cherish most
are being abandoned by those in power
but during this period of so much
hardship i've also seen firsthand the
best of this country
even with a president in the white house
trying to divide us one song
in espanol broke all the barriers across
cultures
languages and ages
de pasquito proved to me that in this
country we will never be defined
by our differences and no matter who is
present
latinos and latinas will always have a
place here
but how much better would it be to have
a president
who celebrates our community instead of
denigrating it that's joe biden
he has spent hispanic heritage month
recognizing
all of the contributions latinos and
latinas have made to our nation he knows
we are not
a monolith we are public servants
military leaders lawyers doctors
nurses teachers artists essential
workers and groundbreakers
who make this country great and joe has
made it clear
that whether your first generation or
your family has been here
for generations you belong in the united
states
as much as anyone else
and as ricky said joe will always be
there for puerto rico
he will never abandon us in our time of
need and working hand in hand with
puerto rico's leaders
he will invest in building and a more
prosperous
future for the place i will always call
home
a future that will make life better for
puerto ricans whether you live on the
island
or on the mainland but while i'm
confident
joe will have our backs as president i
also know
he needs us and that means making our
voices heard
at the ballot box so if you weren't
convinced by
eva and ricky maybe you will be con
convinced by me go to iwillvote.com
seriously do it now register to vote and
make a plan
for when and where you're going to do it
and text
todos to 30330 to find out more ways
to get involved in this campaign nothing
less than the future
of our country is on the ballot in
november
and we cannot let nuestras familias
down hey
i'm honored to present vice president
and the future president of the united
states joe biden
uh
i just have one thing to say
they're going here
there you go
i'll tell you if i had the talent of any
one of these people i'd be
i'd be elected president by acclamation
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank you
and uh hello and happy hispanic hispanic
heritage month
it's great to be back in florida and to
be here to celebrate what is
best in our democracy our diversity
our culture that is shaped by people
from every part of the world
especially the rich hispanic heritage
that enlivens so much of our national
story
we hear it in the rhythms that pour into
our hearts
and move our feet to artists like louise
and ricky and uh
and thank you both thank you both for
being here but more than being here but
thank you for actually
jumping in and trying to help me win
this election
it is where i come from they call that a
big deal it really is
thank you thank you thank you we see it
representative
represented on our television and our
movie screens with actresses like eva
longoria
thank you eva for both joining us
tonight for the outstanding
work you did in hosting the first night
of the democratic convention
you have changed political conventions
forever i don't think we'll ever see one
like the old-fashioned conventions
you did an incredible job you become a
great friend
and thank you thank you thank you for
sticking with me
and we recognized in the halls of power
in our congress and our leaders and like
my friend representative darren soto
who i had the pleasure of speaking with
a few minutes ago i had thanked him for
the passport into his district
i appreciate it congressman uh thank you
for all you do for the people in this
district
and it's uh it's in the scientists
working in labs across the country on
vaccines
to fight this virus to the doctors and
the nurses on the front lines working
around the clock
to care for people's health it's in the
diplomats who proudly represent the
united states of america and our values
in countries all over the world and our
military members and the families who
love this country so much
they're willing to sacrifice everything
for it
it's in the engineers who are working to
develop new technologies that's going to
help us
grasp our clean energy future and the
skilled union craftsman
we're going to build it hispanic
heritage month
is an important reminder of just how
much strength we draw
as a nation from our immigrant roots and
our values as a nation
of immigrants unless you were a native
american or your ancestors were enslaved
and brought here
by force beginning 400 years ago we've
all
come from somewhere else and for most of
us that journey began with a choice
to try for something better here in the
united states
whether it was my ancestors who boarded
coffin ships in the rec
in the famine of the 1840s or families
that fled oppressive regimes
and natural disasters in latin america
in the caribbean
or any of the waves of immigrants
seeking freedom and opportunity
who have continually renewed our
strength
and have given us the the important
capacity
to all of us to speak to speak with grit
and determination
to simply say i can do it i can do it
all of our ancestors yours fine they
came equipped with only one thing
the only thing they had in their pocket
was hope
and in so many ways that's part of what
makes us americans
and for people with hispanic ancestries
those contributions date all the way
back before our founding
there's no separating out hispanic
heritage from american heritage
these stories are one in the same and
growing more
vibrantly entwined every single day
today it is no exaggeration to say
that the future of the success of this
country depends on
depends on hispanics having
opportunities
and the tools they need to succeed you
know
i know my team here knows my new team
that 24 to every 100 kids in school
today speaks spanish
the idea the idea we are not going to
encourage and build
and invest in is just mind-blowingly
stupid
folks in the midst of this god-awful
pandemic
we've seen even more clearly than ever
how much we rely on people with hispanic
roots
to keep our country running again that's
not an exaggeration
so many of our front-line workers are
hispanic
the people stocking the grocery shelves
driving the delivery trucks
working in the meatpacking plants
staffing our nursing homes our hospitals
these include 200 000 dreamers
working in those key roles many of whom
are of hispanic heritage
and we depend on them a lot of people
who are recognized for the first time by
what they truly are
essential what we do we don't just need
to thank them
we need to pay them pay them and treat
them with dignity
my dad just said joey your job's about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect it's about your place in the
community
it's about being able to look your kid
in the eye and say honey it's going to
be okay
and to make sure we're giving hispanic
americans the support and respect they
deserve and need at all times
we have to change our attitudes how can
we have a strong and thriving republic
if we aren't doing more to fully deal in
hispanic communities
and all those communities have for too
long been left out and left behind
to every aspect of american life the
answer is real simple
we won't be able to that's why i've laid
out extensive plans that demonstrate
how we're going to use every tool at our
disposal to take on the inequities of
hurst
communities by number one investing in
economic mobility
improving our educational system rooting
out race-based disparities in our health
care
and building on obamacare taking on the
gun violence that plagues our
communities
and finally building an immigration
system that treats people with dignity
and is true to american values
today i've released my agenda for puerto
rico
even after being president for nearly
four years
donald trump doesn't seem to grasp
doesn't seem to grasp
that the people of puerto rico are
american citizens already
let me think about it
and they deserve to have a leadership in
government that understands that in
america
there is no room for the idea of second
class citizens period we're all equal
all deserving i'm running to be
president
of all america including three million
american citizens living in puerto rico
i'm not going to steal the money that
desperately needed to reconstruct the
island
in order to build a wall along the
border that does nothing to keep
americans safe
i'm not going to suggest that we sell or
trade as was mentioned earlier
puerto rico i'm not going to throw paper
towels at people
whose lives have just been devastated by
a hurricane
the world saw that not just the united
the world saw that
it was mortifying i'm not going to deny
the science of climate change that tells
us
hurricanes are devastating weather
events that will only grow more frequent
and more intense unless we take action
and i'm certainly not going to say what
the president allegedly said to the
department of homeland security
and the national security officials when
they allegedly said
i got it i got it the way to keep these
hurricanes from coming on board is
nuke them whoa
nukem you know
i'm gonna lead i'm gonna respect and
support the islands renewal
and fully recovery including investing
in infrastructure
reconstruction to modernize standards
promote economic development initiatives
to support for families
provide relief for the unsustainable
deaths
that exist on the island and expand
access to education
and workforce development i'm going to
work with representatives who support
each of the status options in puerto
rico on a fair
and binding process to determine their
own status
i happen to believe states would be the
most effective means of ensuring
that residents of puerto rico are
treated equally with equal
representation at a federal level
but the people of puerto rico must
decide
and the united states federal government
must respect and act on that decision
you know and this much is certain a
biden harris administration
will always have the back of every
single american
when they get knocked down i've been
knocked down and many of you have too i
know what it's like
but my dad would say every time you get
99 just get up joey
get up we're going to get up we're going
to honor the incredible contributions
and service of puerto ricans
people from all across the hispanic
diaspora
to this country to this country not only
the names we know and like like
lin-manuel miranda who i was helping me
out
but remember the stories that don't
always make the headlines like puerto
rico's 65th
infantry regiment who general macarthur
described as quote
writing a brilliant record of heroism in
battle
during the korean war how much do you
all hear about that
we'll work to build on obamacare and
expand its protections
so the more hispanic people have access
to high quality affordable health care
that they deserve under the obama body
administration
four million hispanic americans gain
coverage the largest gain of coverage of
any group
president trump is still still trying to
rip obamacare away from people
in the middle of the worst pandemic in a
century
that's on top of the total failure to
manage covet 19 which is now
stolen stolen the lives of 200
almost 200 000 people in america with
disproportionately large share of those
deaths among hispanic communities
over 25 000 deaths
that's on top of the failure to
adequately work to address the economic
impacts in this pandemic
which again have fallen more heavily on
hispanic pocketbooks
more than 25 percent of hispanics here
in florida
have reported being worried about how
they're going to pay their rent or their
mortgage
a study found that one in three hispanic
small business owners
have taken hit during this pandemic with
many more likely to close and close
permanently
that's on top of his failure and in fact
complete disinterest in addressing the
racial injustice crisis in america
he does exactly the opposite he fans the
flames of hatred and division in our
country for his own gain
that's on top of his failure to
recognize the existential threat of
climate crisis
yesterday in california he said sitting
with a group of
scientists i don't think science knows
whether or not
climate change is real that's what he
said
at a time when wildfires are racing
across the west destroying homes and
communities
and another hurricane threatens our
coasts
mr president science
knows science knows
they do know look donald trump has
failed the hispanic community time and
time again and that's not a secret
whether it's in this heinous act of
separating children from their families
at our border
or his repeated attacks on dreamers or
as neglect of the people of puerto rico
after hurricane
maria or his repeated failure to make
sure essential workers have the personal
protective equipment they need
donald trump has done nothing but
assault the dignity of hispanic families
over
and over and over and over again
it's wrong that's not who we are
we have to do so much more than just
defeat donald trump
we have to seize this opportunity to
build back better
for all of our communities because the
end of the day
all the american people are looking for
is a shock
my dad will say the american people just
given half a chance have never
ever ever ever ever let the country down
chance to work hard and get ahead
but you can't do when your community is
always the first and hardest hit
and the last to get help instead of
needed when they need to dig out
i truly believe we have a tremendous
opportunity to turn this moment of
crisis into a moment of progress
on health care wages housing education
and so much more we can reach
for more as a nation we can rebuild the
backbone of this
country and finally bring everybody
along
we can build a new administration that
reflects the full diversity of our
nation
including hispanic communities
hispanic voters especially especially
right here in florida can help put our
nation on a path
moving forward there are now 49 days
left to election day
i'm asking for your vote i'm going to
work very hard every single day to get
it i used to when i first ran as a kid
i'd knock on the door and say my name is
joe biden i'm running for the united
states senate
look me over if you like what i see and
believe what i say
help me out if not vote for the other
guy well i'm here in florida to say
look me over again here in florida all
across the country hope that each and
every one of you
gets involved in this election
sounds like hyperbole exaggeration
but our democracy depends on every voice
being heard and every vote being counted
so please this election
make your vote heard through your
vote your voice is heard make a plan to
vote has been pointed out
make a plan to help your community vote
you know i grew up in a heavily irish
catholic community in scranton
pennsylvania in a heavily
italian polish community in clemont
delaware
these are communities built on two
things faith
and family they've been the core of my
entire life
that's what i come back to again and
again whether it's losing my wife and
daughter in an accident or my son dying
from glioblastoma
it's been the source of my strength and
times of struggle
and my comfort in times of grief faith
and family
it seems to me that's the same strength
that's always animated the hispanic
community
faith and family that's the heritage
we're celebrating this month
and it's profoundly american as well
it's not only our past
it's our future as well and
more than any other time
the hispanic community latino community
holds in their palm of the hand
their hand the destiny of this country
you may not want to hear it but it's
true
it's true you can decide
the direction of this country i've said
many times when i
decided to run i said one of the reasons
why i'm running is restore the soul of
america
it's a basic proposition we're so
much better than we are acting now
the rest of the world is looking as like
what has happened to america
america's always led not just by the
example of our power but the power of
our example
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with a certain
inalienable rights
and it goes on we've never met that test
we've never walked away from before
we've got to keep bending that arc we've
got to keep getting more inclusive
because therein lies the power and the
majesty
of the united states of america i want
to thank you all
particularly thank the people who came
here and introduced me today
and may god protect our troops
god bless you all
got to make the world go round
got to make them
my
so
this